okay so today I want to show you a
fractal see well okay so you may ask you
know what is the zero well see well is
something that solves this equation a
plus x equals a but then you say well
what is a if we are talking about say
the counting numbers you know so we say
one two three and so on
if I am only allowed to use the counting
numbers then I you know X cannot be
there is no counting number that will
solve this question so in the country
the counting numbers do not have zero
well they are the natural numbers do
right so we put zero and then we call
these the natural numbers 0 1 2 3 4 they
do have a 0 it's x equals 0 but this
zero okay so in the natural numbers if
you were going to solve a different
equation for example a plus x equals 0
if in the natural numbers then this only
has one solution if a 0 if a is not 0
then these have no solutions
right so then how do you solve this well
you solve this by then you know having
even more numbers and then talk about
what we call the integers dot dot dot
minus 3 minus 2 minus 1 0 1 2 and so on
in this set these two equations you know
have solutions so there is a 0 and and
you can always solve a plus X equal 0
today I will show you a different type
of number okay they have this very
special 0 that looks like a frat okay
and these new numbers that I will talk
about they're called sandpile so what is
the sample so this is a you know it's
going to be a 3 by 3 green okay and on
this 3 by 3 grid I am going to put
numbers that are either 0 1 2 or 3 so in
every one of these nine cells I'm going
to put either
I want a two or a three and that's going
to be my sand pile so these numbers
represent number of grains of sand that
you put one on one shell in this grid
and so these are my numbers and then I
need to tell you about well what's the
addition how am I going to add them so
for example 1 2 0 2 1 1 0 1 3 let's add
let's say 2 1 3 1 0 1 0 1 ok so I have
it here to sand piles and how do I add
them
well I add them by adding every number
number in itself so if you have 1 + 2
that's going to be 3 2 + 1 that's also 3
0 + 3 3 2 plus 1 is 3 1 plus 0 is 1 1
plus 1 is 2 0 plus 0 is 0 1 plus 1 is 2
3 plus 0 is 2 ok so that's these are my
new numbers and how to add them now I
can run into trouble
yes for example if I change one of these
numbers for example these 1 for a 2 then
I'm going to have 2 + 2 which is 4 and I
am not allowing for so how do I fix that
problem okay and so this is why these
are called sand piles so there is some
dynamic thing that happens in here
and so when I when I'm angry which is 4
it is unstable and it's going to topple
and send the drinks of sand to their
neighbors okay okay now like 1/2 of
cards that's right so in here because
this 4 is in a corner then it has two
neighboring cell okay and then 2 other
you know imagine that this is sitting on
top of our table and then so it's going
to send one kind of sent to these three
and then one will send to this other 3
okay everything else remains the same
and then it's going to lose one going
sent to this edge and one great
Center this edge and now it's going to
have zero now this process created two
new four so then I have to repeat it
again because remember my rules is that
the entries have to be between zero and
three and you do this process until you
have no more force and here as you see
we created one yet one more force we
need to repeat this process and that's
the addition of the two samples that we
have at the beginning okay so then the
question is do we have a free will in
this in this set of samples and well it
turns out that it's you know from the
definition of of this addition the zero
is unsurprisingly zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero here if I add
anything to this I am NOT going to do
anything well that was sort like a
boring theorem and it is boring because
if I want to solve an equation like a
plus x equals zero where this is one you
know every single thing is a sample then
this equation has no solutions so if I
put two samples together you know if I
have a sample a and a sample X and I put
them together I will never be able to
topple everything until I get a 0 there
is no - a sand pile it doesn't exist and
the reason ok so if we if we put numbers
into our sand pile so we say a 1 a 2 a 3
a a a 9 so we put nine numbers you know
and this is like the result of some
addition then there will there will be
top links okay there will be top links
but at the end of the day you loose and
only if you are on the edge of this grid
but however every single time you are on
an edge can get sent to another
neighboring cell so you will never be
able to get rid of entire sent so there
is no - a sand pile so how do we fix
that in the natural number okay we fix
that by making them bigger into the
integers so we threw a
all the negative numbers and here we're
going to do something different we are
actually going to shrink our set so what
is the step that we're considering we
are considering every single sample with
this so are the set that we're
considering let me call it m and this
set M is the set of all sand piles all
sand piles on the three by three grid
yes we're a sand pile is just a
collection of nine numbers where every
number is between zero one two or three
and in fact how many such fun paths are
there we have nine cells this cell can
be a 0 a 1 a 2 or a 3 so it has four
possibilities this cell has also four
possibilities this arrow has four
possibilities as well so a basic
counting says that we have four to the
nine total and piles and this number
happens to be two hundred and sixty-two
thousand one hundred and forty-four so
this is the set of all sand pile but now
we're going to shrink it okay so we are
not going to consider all the sand piles
we are just going to consider a smaller
collection of them and that smaller
collection is the collection of samples
that I can obtain by starting with the
all three yes do threes is the sample
that has the most sense okay and then
I'm going to add whatever I want to add
to it and when I'm done you know the
resulting sand pile is going to be in my
new collection okay so the new
collection the smaller collections is
all the samples that I can obtain from
the old threes by adding extra sand and
then toppling so for example if I add
just one grain of sand in the center
cells then well I have everywhere threes
except a four in here all you're going
to start a big top right now yes yes so
I start toppling and so these four is
going to send one grain of sand to each
of its four neighbors
so three four three four zero four three
four three I have now for unstable birds
if I can topple them all simultaneously
so each of them is going to lose four
grains of sand so now they are going to
be zeros they are going to send each is
going to send one grain of sand to the
center so now the center has four grains
of sand again and the corners will
receive one grain of sand from one side
and one grandson - from the other so now
the corners have five
okay and we need to repeat this process
these four is going to send one grain of
sand to each of its neighbors now it has
zero
the corners are still 5 we topple the
corners and we get you know they are
going to lose four grains of sand so
each corner will have one at the end and
then these numbers going to get one
grain of sand from here one grand-slam
from these other five so now they are
going to be pleased so that is part of
my new set this is part of my new set
correct yes so these new sets
okay have many many samples you know the
original set had two hundred and
sixty-two thousand one hundred forty for
our new set so this I said that I'm
going to call F which is the sand piles
arising from the old three it's much
smaller it's about a half it's half as
big it has more or less a hundred tough
now one we have one big problem here and
the big problem is that the zero zero
zero zero zero zero zero zero zero is
not in because you know we start from
max we add sand to it we are never going
to get rid of all the cent
so this zero is not in our sub
collection so we lost our zero we wanted
to find sort of the - sand pile and now
we have even a bigger problem which is
we don't have a fever
however let me show you just a couple of
these computations as you can see they
take a little bit of time so let me show
you just a couple more computations okay
okay so it turns out okay that the old
tooth is in s it is you can get also you
can get co2 so this all Q's is the old 3
plus 1 3 1 3 3 3 1 3 1
and also let me show you another one
that another element that is in X so
these elements 2 1 2 1 0 1 2 1 2 is also
less so now I'm going to add these two
new sand piles that are you okay so I'm
going to add the 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 so
the old 2's plus this new element that
we go 2 2 1 2 1 0 1 2 1 2 if I add them
then I gave the 4 3 4 3 2 3 4 3 4
yes and I have 4 in the corners so I'm
going to topple them and so each of the
force is going to lose four grains of
sand so now I'm going to have zeros in
the corners and then these three is
going to receive one greater than from
this for another grain of sand from
these other four so now they're going to
be five sides and I still have a two in
descent ok so now all the files topple
and we are going to lose four grains of
sands all the files are going to be now
one okay they are going to send each
value and send one grand ocean to the
center so now the center sale has two
plus four meaning 6 threads of sand and
then each of the corners is going to get
1% from each side so now they are going
to have to and v6 will topple is going
to lose four grains of sand and we get
the all twos back this is something that
it's a little bit surprising ok so we
have to some parts we have the old tools
and then we have this other sand pile we
put it on top of each other and we get
the old tools back so it's acting like a
zero and in fact if we were to do this
computation again on the all three
or on any other sample in F we will get
the same sample so the zero in our new
set F R 0 is these two one two one zero
one two one two
so that will have that effect on any
other stand hold in air correct correct
and the maximum MAGIX and it's the
automatic sample and in fact it can be
used to separate these two sets like the
things that are in s and the things that
are not if you are a fan pile that it
doesn't come from the old trees okay
then you're not going to get the same
sample after you add like a test you can
apply it's a text yes it's a test
oh that's a good question so what do you
think that should happen I think it
should result in itself we can check
that yes
so to each cells we could have just
multiply every entry by two butts okay
so let's do it four four two four two
zero two four two four again we have
fours in the corners they are going to
topple zero in the center and when the
fourth bubble you know they are going to
be going to zero the news for grains of
sand the corners are going to receive
two grains of sand each and the center
is going to get one grain of sand from
each of the fourth I need to topple the
center and I get exactly two one two one
zero one two one two
yes that's you know the addition of this
element plus itself is equal to 2 1 2 1
0 1 2 1 what do we call that special
power I call it a magic power token I am
well we call it the identity some pile
but you know it's also the zero of this
set so we indeed call it a favor let me
show you yet one more beautiful property
of this zero remember at the beginning
we had these equations a plus x equals 0
now our zero is these two one two one
two
one two one two it turns out that in s
we can always solve these equations so
there is always a - sand pile on s we
can always solve this question so this
set s has you know it behaves in sort of
like the integers
they each have a zero but it also has
you know this additive inverses this - a
sand pile you know if we start from the
all three right so what could I add here
to the old trees to get to this zero
sand pile so is there such a thing as -
a sample something that I absolutely -
get to zero but let's see so if I add 3
3 3 3 1 3 3 3 3 I get the serum sample
in this very specific set we created
this is a negative sample that's right
this is minus D all three this is what I
add - took the old trees to get to the
zero but the river I had something else
there so for example are you old - yes
that wouldn't have a negative effect
correct correct
this - sand pile is unique for the old -
I have 2 3 2 3 2 3 2 3 2 this is also
the zero sample and actually these works
for any sample that comes from Max from
the old tree okay I can always find a -
sand pile so this 0 it's you know it's
it's very special I told you about you
know that at the beginning I was going
to talk about fractals Ewell's
this doesn't look like a fractal I mean
it's very pretty but it doesn't look
like a fractal so let me now tell you
about fractals ok we can play the same
game that we have played on a 3x3 grid
we can play it on any grid for example
on the 2x2 grid and if we play it on a
2x2 grid vit tall so there is also an
identity and the identity is very simple
is the all -
is that the identities for what set the
Mac set yes we have a 2x2 grid and we
look at the Sun piles on the 2x2 grid
that come from max max in this case is
three three three three three
so this is the zero sand pile on a two
by two green on a three by three grid
well it's you know the one we have
competed two one two one zero one two
one two okay we could do this on a 3x3
grid on a 4x4 or even on rectangular
grids like at you know five by ten or
something like this so let me show you a
few more zeros okay
so this is the 3x3 what about a four by
four combo should look like 2 3 3 2 3 2
2 3 3 2 2 3 2 3 3 2 they we always have
to have some symmetry because you know
we are you know the grid itself you know
it's very symmetric so we can continue
doing this we can let me show you
maybe one more or a few more let me show
you the 5x5 ok so a 5x5 is a 2 3 2 3 2 3
2 1 2 3 2 1 0 1 2 3 2 1 2 3 2 3 2 3 2 so
they have some structure okay that is so
they are symmetric and we can there is
actually an algorithm to compute every
single one of these seals for any
rectangular grid so but this algorithm
is you know not an algorithm you know
for small cases it produces them very
fast but in very large creature it will
take you know maybe a lifetime to
complete this but we can compute let's
say for example a 400 by 400 ok so let
me show you the picture so this is the 0
sand pile on a 400 by
400 greets and it's full of colors so
let me explain to you the colors the
black means zero grains of sand the
yellow means one grain of sand blue
means two and red means three and as you
can see in this picture there is yes a
lot of symmetry but then there is also
this fractal structure that they have
and in fact so this is something that is
very interesting to people you know to
try to describe exactly what type of
fractal structure do we have so I had a
1 million by 1 million grid it would
find this somewhere within it
correct correct yes and and you know so
we know a few things about this this
type of fractals but not a lot
ok so roughly you know the you know so
you may ask for example what is the
density of these these pictures so how
many grains of sand you know in average
are on a cell and well you know it has
to be in less than 3 it turns out that
it has to be bigger than 2 okay and it's
more or less 2.1 okay it's close to the
point so it's really not to in fact you
know we can you know generalize this say
we I showed you how to do this with
grids but we can do this with other type
of grades like hexagonal grids and
triangular grids and get different
levels different sets we could even play
this game with an infinite grid and very
interesting things happen when you play
on infinite grids would you like to see
so what I'm going to show you is an
image created created by Wesley penguin
where you have an infinite grid and then
you put lots and lots of sent to one
cell and then you topple and see what
happens so in this case we're going to
put two to the theory number of grains
of sand in one cell and then we're going
to topple and see what happens
and the picture that we get is the this
type of picture it's also you know
fractal blue is 0-2 displayed on an
infinite grid so
so when you topple you're going to reach
your there is going to be some perimeter
and then after that you're not going to
have grains of sand so zero is blue then
a lighter blue is one yellow is two and
ready three it's very interesting that
you know the picture that you get looks
sort of like a circle so there's a bunch
doesn't just send grains of sand
everywhere but it sort of like preserves
the circular structure and we can even
zoom in this picture and see what
happens
so we can zoom in and you see that there
is this sort of fractal type structure
and you know things that you know only
by looking very very close we see you
know that very intricate things are
happening right so we can play this with
different types of grips this is a you
know a triangular grid and this is again
pulling lots and lots of grains of sand
in one cell and then toppling and in
here you know we have more neighbors per
cell so our max you know before we
topple weak you can put larger piles of
censoring here we can put all the way up
to five and that is stable so we have
more colors and then it produces this
type of also fracture looking picture
point goes back to itself so we know
that this point is on the straight line
because it intersects the circle
inversion